well
[Music]
we continue with the coverage of a shooting
that occurred on Tuesday night in a
business in Samuel where
Cristian Cásseres greets you with his
informative watch of jeans now in Spanish, a
man is dead and an employee is
seriously injured apparently on
suspect followed the victim
into a business where the shooting broke out
and he died the restaurant is
located on charles de lighthouse
center according to the metropolitan police
everything happened a little
after 7:45 p.m.
the leak if you have more
information you are asked to
contact the police
and I tell you that a driver
crashed into the wall of a house
ending up in the pool this happened
around 2 in the morning near
see viure and wilmer the police  said
the driver suffered minor injuries no one
else was hurt due to this
incident however authorities
believe the man was driving intoxicated  o
and you feel the flow of people inside the
international airport they want me
due to the celebrations
for thanksgiving day thousands of travelers are anticipated
during the
holiday weekend officials recommend arriving
two to three hours before your
flight since  the lines to the
security checkpoint will be long and we close at
a glance with the temperatures
we will have some breezes for
wednesday with highs in
the 60s the winds will not be as strong
by thanksgiving
however we will have sunny skies for
the  weekend i am cristian cásseres
with informative hat from spanish i news now
good day